charis levert short on the three another
rebound for westbrook
up ahead here's hachimura he'll go up
with the left quickly before turner can
get back
if you ask me jk so far so good
and they swiped down on him taking it
away but there's
westbrook with a steal up ahead to
hachimora he was rewarded
the basketball gods
[Applause]
but this is called shooting the gap and
usually
coaches are mad at guys that hot
chamorro now on levert
who steps back that's a three it's off
lopez nice box out of sabonis
westbrook taha shamura beautiful touch
pass there by westbrook
and rui hachimora of physicality right
now
trying to make it to the half without
three fouls
westbrook the in and out dribble gets by
turner and turner just let him go by you
see that he didn't
not want to go challenge wizards leading
by
three westbrook tries the three
got it russell westbrook with his third
three of the game he's got 32 points
russell knowing that you have
miles turner that's a mismatch
westbrook against turner again step back
for
three russell westbrook does it again
westbrook
miles turner once again giving him that
space having a respected drive and
shooting this
over the nba's leading shot blocker